yeah in a row with streaming and I'm
making uh made it to a shield arena this
is gonna be a rapid arena ten minutes
it's an eight hour long tournament and I
think it started like a couple hours ago
got just over two hours ago
I'm playing a player rated just over a
thousand let's bezerk
I'm gonna try and work my way up the
standings a little bit chests currently
leading this is hilarious I've not run
into this opening in a long time
Nakamura used to play this consistently
in in Bullitt and blitz back in the ICC
days
um I think I'm knowledgeable enough to
know what to do here already lack is
winning a piece
make that a queen
I'll open up the chat here my knucks not
sure if I recognize that name hello
Annika
I had to see an ad first that's because
I'm a twitch partner if you subscribe I
don't think you have to see ads I think
that's how it works
can take this on Bill attacking the rook
if you place f3 I have Queen h4 check
the goal is to win as quickly as
possible and then move on
uh yeah IM has two meanings like i am an
international master though
nice double meaning
that was a nice game
that game brings me back to childhood
when people would just like trying
scholars mate you and then they would
hang their queen
hypothesis
under the chess it's okay okay so
playing a slightly better player I'm
still black I'll desert again I just
want to work my way up to place and some
stronger players
here we have a more normal opening I'm
gonna play two nights
as usual my repertoire Bishop b3
looks like an overly safe move
usually when I play weaker players or at
least look rated players I'll play
King's pawn
I found those or opportunities to win
quickly
Bishop g4 and 94 is the main idea I'm
gonna play a six first I'm preventing
any night a four with the forcing of the
rate of the Bishop Bishop a seven also
I'm waiting for him to castle play
Bishop g4 Knight g5 usually isn't that
great because after castling it's not
that great for white to take on f7 and
now I'm ready to play each six or 94-94
looks attractive
he's going to play queen g3
and then maybe h6
you
get some attack
maybe each six and then
I don't know
I did beserk don't have too much time to
think
the h6 first
I think he's going to play Knight f3
and he's threatening bishop take h6
but I do have to be careful probably
have King h7 though just defend
everything
Knight h5 might be coming
should've considering 9h five that would
have just shot the Queen
setting
this position Knight h5 if you play
Queen h4 I would take and then the Queen
let's clean each for here
trapping McQueen
okay and after win
more slowly
her still have to win quickly Oh what do
I do
okay I'll give him a taste of his own
medicine
95 comes
a bit discomforting
now Knight g5 should not hurt me is my
g5 King d8 and then he's in the cities
like pinned znation chess with the sub
Thank You znation eight months in a row
I think that's my yeah he's he's not
only my supreme Oh way he called me the
Supreme Leader well he's a supreme
subscriber
and hello to that boy travel
good to see you and hello more in ski
look good to see you
I'll rated do I have to be if I want to
be coached by an ion I mean different
ions coach different players some ions
don't coach at all I usually am open to
coaching players of all levels
I like
I enjoy the variety of students and I
get to work with so if you are
interested in coaching you can send me a
message
or you could go to a beach s org slash
coach and then find the coach listing oh
he hung his queen this is why I wanted a
few moves ago
so this is a second game in a row well
are hanging their queen
okay he would just resigns that's nice
ah off to a good start
did I watch Norway chess I have not been
following Norway chess too closely I
have been seeing results I saw that ding
broke his hip
I saw the like the video of all the
players making food is probably about to
win the bit to 2,700 chess
I should really look at the games Oh
Fabiana got off to a bad start
but he's about to win he's only plus-one
I was he about to win
the fact that ding dropped out maybe is
those things off
oh he's about to win this game
I should check that ok another dessert
we just he's working too
you
like PT 2
I play Knight bTW - first to prevent any
94
Madigan's
I'm 903
efore move I wanted to prevent I think I
can take and then 92 now he's forced to
play f5
on how
give me mallets
clear I'll play see for
as box overextended
but be we maybe f3 at some points
you
I'm just gonna develop now put my pieces
on good squares and not force matters
too quickly
villager with a picture of position
it could look soon be five
you
ah 93 I guess I like my position
it's just it's a weird position and take
some more mental energy figure out the
right moves
rather of taking opening up the D file
probably doesn't win anything you can
take with bishop
now I get the bishop pair
reading this slightly more positionally
that's Queenie five ideas [ __ ] he
really has no attack f4 doesn't work as
bishops kind of stuck
wendy6 looks fun
a c5 week
we'll probably play Queen b6 which I
sort of figure out about then I'll play
b3 he'll play rook b8 I'll play Queen f4
or maybe I'll play Queen c7 one points
wait a minute place Queen b6 p 3r if T
it is rip d2 in the end
maybe if he plays Queen v6 I'll play
this in this
probably listening to everything I'm
saying be quiet oh wait a minute
I'm also threatening East six maybe even
if he's listening to everything I'm
saying and help him too much
missing things
we take a look at the Carolina position
Wow okay this is completely winning for
Fabi
there's too many pawns
and rooks and a bishop the game still
going I unexpected he wants to play out
for
I four is actually annoying threats
want to take on c5 loses a bishop
it can get away with this
a weird position
Zephyr is now defended through my queen
so he could take and then playoff for
but then I play Bishop h4
my Bishop's a bit awkward but it should
not be getting trapped as you could play
h6 here
each six doesn't threaten g5 because
then I can take and then take
oh I think things are under control
in the meantime my bishop is actually
somewhat effective controlling d8 so he
can't fight for the only open file on
the board
I'll just double up
maybe I'll go for Bishop h5
by bishops coordinates in a weird way
edge of the board age six is now
weakening because now I have access to
g6 and then II four will be weak
and his rook asked to move debating
between this and this and this
and this
Brooke t7 Oh No
I want them back being made him somehow
if he plays a night here that would be
nice
I haven't been looking at the chat
because I had this this image open in
Faviana
from axe villager some plungers
he's plus two oh he's plus two after
this game I see that's cool
it's so crazy like just last month I was
in a room with murmur Fenske and Fabiano
and we were playing bughouse
Fabiana is about
when Norway chess
zees in first place friends
- I don't know what I want to do
just want to reminisce about good
memories maybe a three
it's really helped me
a position so good
Knight is annoying
I will play now maybe just f3
ski
you
I'm just going to tickle this rook
doesn't really do anything
ah fate but hopefully I'll make him
think I might put my bishop on e6
but then he has g5 nevermind
I admit that it's basically pretty
pointless
now he was just repeating I'm gonna play
h3 making roof for the king
to bug me last night about streaming
wait did you bug me
remember being vote
but I take doesn't work
let's take care
so annoying I'm gonna bring the king to
eat too
and wants to play rugby though
strugglin
okay I have a plan I'm going to take
care
I'll take with paw and then I play f3
have more scope
you
because if I tried that three right away
he could have taken on ether be a little
bit annoying but now there's there's so
much pressure isn't his nights not gonna
stay on g3
I can play rugby aids
play 95 and then we'll get some endgame
or I'll just be up upon
ending messages and me chest chat
I honestly was not aware San Diego
usually I I'm a hard person to bug
get bugged easily
I'm just used to it
cooze
Fabiano one that's exciting
oh so the ratings should update now we
refresh their ratings page
let's take more pawns
up 6-points not that take more pawns
you
okay just a matter of converting
I don't even remember playing a cm I was
pretty tired towards the end of
yesterday's stream i streamed too long
as it takes energy to play chess and
talk
remember things
keep my rope here threatening this he'll
play nine f7
or not
well seven would have been a really
annoying move
you
okay um anything notable in this game
and I just enjoy the London
this is just the one nuance like 92 is
usually the structure is fun for whites
hello real pong so many eyes
to the G yeah
or anyone who's subscribed on just Toth
there's a G to the G emotes
not just me and Andrew Tang who love the
London lot more people and the places
helium put a dragon this game
dragons and mother hoping to play for
what never mind we're playing amaura
oopsie
you want some made me like my first
opponent
you
at any time we can transpose into Mora
that would be intent with this place III
is that all being some preparation
you
are you laying some line ePHI of my
chief or Bishop f4 I take e5 hitting
this
there's a ch3
194 so he's actually he wants to play e5
now it's signs of a d6
and I am up upon
ie five looks really attractive
anything
you'll still want sapui5 okay 95 here's
this check
we trade Inhumans back his pawn
I'm gonna play you five
five makes this bishop happier but it
makes my pawns happier as well now I
just want to do this
nga go with the sub Thank You San Diego
you appreciate that
working let me open up street lamps
miss many more Turkey
the nice position
I just have to watch out for time Oh
real pond thanks for the follow and sky
drones so thank you for the follow be
still watching
you finally play c3
they have to take I played Bishop u6
that might be leaking beginning
play Knight g5 and Queen
please
have to play a bit quicker
let me ask you guys did the when people
sub or follow did it appear on stream
you did it have the usual notification
like all I would have seen it
I'm going to go for this
realizing that
he takes take 9527 Quincy for the very
worst I've 98
line
I also have to be careful
pick with night and debating between
this and this
you
the thing with the these moral positions
this half-open file on this open file
you usually give white some common
sation
so it's just a matter of not plundering
anything there are no notifications
what's going on browser source it's here
at new
I'm sorry about that
trying to fix it do like a test thing
I tested such a small interface
you
alert box
you
woman here
I really don't want to okay test
donation
that's so weird
you
I don't want to click on this because
like it gives a key
is usually a bit sensitive
uhh
you
you
it's hard to try and fix the thing and
then play the game at the same time
I hope I know each five
you
this stopped working
if I plate 9h five right away here
denied a key five so that's why I'm
playing coming out 749 h5 and I want to
play that f4 someday
like a test although anything working
nothing's working
take the risk
but it didn't stop on stream
let me try
Hey
okay now it should be working
um yeah that was just that was weird I
don't know probably it forgot I had to
remind it
now I have to move quicker
if anyone can follow or subscribe or
donate just to make sure the
notification is working not just me
testing it but it should be working
um and actually twitch does not allow
you to subscribe to yourself I'll admit
that I did try it using twitch Prime but
they they have a little message you
cannot subscribe to yourself
aku's with the 50 bits okay it is
working
thank you for the test a very generous
test
okay
with Russian da
eighty-five that's probably weakening
much quicker they follow
hmm
eh bloody Fox thank you for the follow
while I played Queen here Oh actually
Queen there's a blunder I take e5 I'll
go for this
on our queen
you
not what I wanted but I have to make
sure this can be defended
White's getting compensation
you
you
this is going to take work if I want to
win this
yeah he's winning the pond
my time is bad
do
oh yeah weird move
I play Knight d5 at some points
access doli thanks for the follow
okay this is not
good time to get distracted
you
going for this line
is going to be equal
material is already equal of a queenside
majority
lirik be
yes move
these eye neighbors are tricky time
situation makes it even trickier
I think this can be defended
you
hoping the sign works
you
be safe
95 after King r7
oh no when
upon
ah that's really annoying
you
doing
you
okay I'm 22 seconds
I don't know if I'm playing for a win or
a draw
I guess I'll play for it when and if
it's a draw and that's life
if I lose that's death
please hang your rook
nights are tricky
support oh he missed it
and now I'm winning
as so generous of him
that's one of the the most easily
overlooked moves in chess is a backwards
Knight move
seconds two converts
enough time
this
you
my technique is not that impressive here
but hopefully it's good enough
it's time to start pre moving everything
you
okay that was nice I meant to play Queen
a for their not so not Queen b6 well I
tell all my students this move takes
slightly less effort uh okay that was I
was a close call
I have a good position from the opening
but
now maybe e5 wasn't the best move then
quite definitely has condensation in
this position
you
maybe I should play a six first prepare
this
okay back to tournaments
moving up in the world
or wins in a row
for five hours left
was in first place uber but he's passed
lots of people was irken
five
I'll [ __ ]
Oh little Plotkin his name is so bright
green
I barely read it
little plot is a little clock in playing
like I'm in the chest is too slow for
him
even five-minute chasis probably too
slow for him
let's play let's play this line or
have a feeling like he was going for
some hippo setup g5
a d4
these are the right approach when they
played this early g5 is to play f4
interesting
like Bishop t3 I want to play d5 and
Bishop g6
you
is pressure
and now this looks attractive
some key lines here like if he plays g4
I probably took first
you can't play out five because then I
take
these positions are all about opening up
the center for black
and she stabilized
I'll take with this one or this one I
don't know
I'll take with this fun because it kills
us Bishop and I want to play this in
this
for this
now I want to play this this and then
this
all about controlling DS so he could
very possibly play d5 or d6 here but
then I take and his pawn structure will
be of optimal
[ __ ]
I just want a sack on g5
start with g4
you
each for I didn't see that move but I
can take
you
and then g5
this is better than sacking as I'm
opening up the position
and I'm not giving away material
you
and this is gonna be fun I'm gonna have
like all my pieces attacking the king
looks maybe
is queen g4 first
right so this for this for this
you
he has to play Kenichi in the h6
let's seal the deal
if you take sunny to excel take on each
floor of the rook
the ancient gamer view back
go with the sauna session
is in San Diego basically a big sauna in
the in the summer the weather like
really hot that was nice
now that was a nice line against this
hippo or Pierce whatever going for the
h4 h5
there's a lot of people trouble
Alex back
a new name
Alex
and ER Cal let's beserk again
I think I've gained any rating points
your opponent started to low-rated he's
about to lose on time
nevermind ill player Budapest
three let's play 96
I think
for I have three minor pieces developed
and using nothing develops life is good
boop ND requesting the Budapest you
request that before the game started
uh that was nice
okay I'm gonna take on c3
hundred eighty Fahrenheit
Oh
at
you
like that is a compliment
at least most people
these are the planets to play f5
I'll play 94 like a weird move I just
want to play at five and then probably
move back at some points
yes to defend this pawn to
and this is resemblance resembling some
kind of news oh wait a minute if I play
f5 his plays Bishop d3 oh then I have a
knight c5 that's a nice square for them
and then planning a fork probably has to
move back
for for just house
like Bishop d7 I just want to see what
he plays also preventing rook t1 is a
four that makes sense he wants to play
this but you can't play that just
oof
you
probably at some point I'll play f4 like
right now
that's basically what I was waiting for
I like the bishop to move and now
there's less pressure on f4 now I have
many or attacking ideas before is
probably the biggest threats
box it is this a queen trap I can take
and then I can trap this queen if he
takes back
feel good attic
guess it doesn't feel too good for him
there is how he feels that was nice it's
a solid game yeah it's um NIMS online
which i guess also come from a budapest
that's the thing about the budapest
if white declines it it's usually just a
good position for black or a comfortable
opening at least
gained one rating pointless tournaments
bad start
moving up
I'm halfway to first place
okay we're gonna have a ready
born ready for them
or d4 repeat like to play b5 here
preventing a horn move
I'm chooses a lot of people
a lot of times in Bullitt people will
pre move see or and then I just take
always
okay four is usually met with before
you
do I play or stream as your full-time
job I got this question yesterday or
similar question what do I do for a
living
um playing and streaming our kind of
side jobs
um actually playing I don't consider a
job there's very little money and at
least in playing a tournaments
uh but coaching is probably my primary
job
but I don't really do anything full-time
I just do a lot of jobs and projects
and keep it interesting
things I do I do remotely that's my 96
here boys
right
I think I mentioned this yesterday but I
probably have like six or seven
different types of jobs between coaching
okay streaming um doing like freelance
photography and web development I do
some investing what else do I do do some
work for st. Louis chess club
I just finished recording this online
course on the London
work for us chest as well doing their
twitter feed
Oh
I'm still exploring and trying to figure
out what I want to do full-time
a good move and this attacks this
unleashes a bishop I didn't beserk
against this guy that's a good thing so
now I have time to think
I was playing as if I desserts
it just been so used to it
you
I'm not sure if 96 is a threat if it's
on the threat I can just continue with a
move like Bishop a6
basic c5 Knight c4
wasn't
at bishops e6 knight c6 Bishop a
six-night c6 Queen d7
back T 5
obviously
the main goal for luck I just want him
to relieve the tension on tension which
is annoying because in
slightly intoxicated bishop there
um
if you place c5 it makes me happy if he
takes it makes me happy
93 doesn't make me happy
I wanted to play Queen before but then
I'm
it please c5
that's a wave
I was the threats
it's annoying I want to play rook c8
here but then here and probably goes
pardon
you
do
the queen bee 496
Ventris
you
also there's a line queen bee 1486 queen
d6
let's do it
was like winged before is not the type
of look like wants to play in puts
taking advantage of the fact this rook
can't move to be one because I down to
the defending the night
I was thinking that I might want to play
Queen a5
and it still ran into 96
you
I guess I have some idea of taking on a
four but probably not soon given it
would be happy if a file opens
last a cold asking if I'm playing the
whole tournament
I don't know what time does it end
five hours and the Saturn
go for a run at five
maybe you wanna do if like if somehow I
keep winning and I'm in the running for
first place
I will
wilfer run and then play from my phone
as I charge my phone
you
our juries
charged
I do not go for runs often that's why I
wanted to go for a run just to do
something good for myself
okay so he plays c5 which was one of the
goals
doing this hole
operation
now it's a question what do I do next
see
Mena's kind of stuck
you
I guess I'll play nice see it in 97 too
97 96 Queen here high-five
ninety-seven maybe makes more sense
you
it's a weird position it looks just bad
for lack
after night season
Pikul pawn hundred bits out of nowhere
thank you pickle pawn
my goal is just to remove this night
long-term positional
when like if the Knights got traded and
we the structure like calms down this
Bishop is no longer as effective my this
ship is happy
my queen is actually a bit annoying for
him even though it's a potential targets
and easily attack its
but now he easily attacks it but now
okay Queen B seven
uh he wants to weigh 97 and then c6
okay let's calculate queen bee 797 King
h8 c6 Queen back to B for hitting the 97
take on d5
you
on take d5 point eighty seven point six
playable position
wait a minute if I play queen bee 797
King Nietzsche is rook b1 and that's
actually trapping the Queen and that
would be verifying
to play queen c3 here the only move
slime for him
recalled RHP one
well now I'm not so comfortable I
thought queen bee 7 would have solved my
problems it's good that I didn't play it
immediately
I saw idea from him
I was close to playing it I saw c6 and I
saw coming before
rookie one such a crazy move
I'm p5f to take
what I want black is definitely worse
here
now the a file opens in his favor
bringing upon
you
probably winning upon
like weensy for
you
time to be useful with my queen
actually some of his
we points
a good thing is as bishop has no role in
the position
this is a solid structure it's just a
matter of kind of taming his plan on the
queenside
and I'm not gonna say anything here
because might be watching listening to
everything
I want to give away too much
23 is a good move
you
you
yeah bucks in trouble
probably allow the trouble actually
but we have to take
wait I see I see a way potentially solve
my problems
a six
let's just see what he does
you
walking on a very thin line the idea is
to play 98
try and simplify
you
you
you
okay I'm gonna
I was trying to read the chat but
difficult
probably look at the time after I end up
losing this game
he's playing very well
yeah this is sad
it's not completely over he's just
defending the a pawn really well
you
I'm sure what to do here
some ideas
thanks for the follow
laundry castle
I 4 + f4 let's play at 5 maybe a g6
or under all things for the follow
ah this isn't going to be very
unpleasant as to do this
you
in the kingdom
you
acting rugby 7:00
you
as bishop is still shut out though
right gasps follow
other good thing is it could turn into a
time scramble
last time offers me some hope there this
you
actually this is a good move
I'm okay with repealing wanna draw
completely okay with that be really
going to take a draw
I have to think so I don't want to draw
but how do I play for a win in this
position
it seems content with a draw
mmm that bugs me I wanted to like try
and win this
you
oh he just takes a draw Oh cuz we
repeated three times I didn't have a
choice that's unfortunate like he should
play for a wins
on the verge of winning I guess maybe he
didn't see a winning plan I was thinking
that he should just like over this rook
p1 through p8
you
for him
you
I don't know also he had some plan
so much time in this position like I'm
just stuck he couldn't just maneuver his
bishop like a maze but I would get
another plan for him
okay back to tournaments interesting
game
my winning streak awesome rating points
not the end of the world
at least I didn't bezerk that game but I
was just in the habit of his raking
every game
speaking of desert king lady for
six we'll have another one of these h4
lines
you
usually black has three options he can H
5 H 6 or 9 s 6
h5 lt4
you
for Bishop g5 the one thing about this
line is this g5 Square is more useful
for whites
se5
I take the ideas to play Queen a5
have a funny idea I'm going to take is
going to play Queen a5
high passivity
was a be good
maybe it's firewall bread it's just now
an easy position to play for whites
and that's what I want
you
maybe I shouldn't have given them well
if he takes on the c3 I have two bishops
now
okay
Singh
I could win the c-pawn
give up my pressure I also would give up
the bishop here play Bishop c4
threatening this and also threatening
this
did someone ask a question
I just ignored
aiyah from pH 1256 hi Eric could you
play gioco piano with C 3 and D for
Bishop before Chuck can I take you for
yeah I can play that if I have an
opponent that played easy five but is pH
still watching because if you're not
still watching I'll play what other
people recommend
so Bishop e6 rook a7
looks Pleasant for whites
I'll break through
apply e5
it's a temporary pond sacrifice
as obvious
and then the point is I'm gonna win back
the pond um day
it has my c6 here
at least I've killed his pawn structure
I'm completing developments
who I went back his pawn and now I apply
more pressure to the bishop I tagged
this I threatened the fork hey life is
good you should have played knight c6
a
you
that was nice is he gonna play on
you
you
the goal is to go for some mating attack
just end the game as quickly as possible
you
wait are the notifications not working
anymore you can't share anymore
someone give one bit just to test this
in the laboratory
I'll check stream labs
or someone followed
thanks for the follow oil frito
I'm just paying soon so I have to start
speak Animus
a a bit from master Gill
or I'm kuester Gill
whatever that name is
take this
lead with my rooks
I smell checkmate
further away
here's a funny movie
my bishop
you
not that easy to checkmate the king
five
Bishop d8
it should be me
what is this position
forcing the king up
as hobby' as media
my hobbies too actually
the media's are pretty
term
this is going to be a very aesthetic
mates
consider it art
he's gonna try and delay the game even
further Navy he sees I'm threatening
this Bay then c5 is he gonna play route
d5
you
audio-video in French nice
he plays rook d5 I predicted his move
you
maybe I should have played kinky one
should have listened to been Feingold
you
oh no I didn't have time for kinky one
can be can be won in this position he
would make me okay
good thing I didn't play can be won
I am to destroy
you
I have the opposition
force made into
if I take it would be sell me that's a
nice last trick
you
okay nice game
like awhile too in that happens when
don't have a queen
you
you
there's one reason to play on these
weird stalemate tricks the very end
what line when you're recommending its
d4 against one against one point four
wait what
I think you forgot you forgot a letter
before the four so I don't know if
you're asking about c4 or d4e for
it will be zurk
you
everyone's playing g6 today what is it
with this cheese fix I'm gonna play this
line again
or h5
do the same thing
I meant a 4 or Provenza and b5 with a
friend
to play the Kings gambit against
six
apologize
the people who want to see the Kings
gambit
six makes me happy
now you slightly weaker
idea of h4 is to play h5 and try and
create weaknesses as early as possible
that's why he played h5m self to prevent
prevent me from playing h5
backing this pawn
and now we can see g6 is probably the
the major weakness
play nights too
I want to build a pressure on
you
oh he can win the pond
it doesn't
you
I'm going to play simple chess I'm going
to take if he takes with Queen I trade
in the my play Knight f4
anyone's t4
you
far enough
so here he takes
I'll just play c3
this is not what I wanted it's still a
pleasant position
feels like I could have done better
I'll play positional
ideas of rook h3 in rep g3
defend with rook t6
space
and diego leaving is my extended accent
recording a video
I used to be very into video production
um I still have interests
never pursued it as much as I wanted to
you
the I'm more into taking photos
national
longer these arenas
those are two
Arina this arena is built over four
hours left
5:35
you
eating whether to play a speaker
Newark's
upon sacrifice if he takes I have some
uh open file
if he plays c6 my goal is to play 90
and it's actually a pretty simple
maneuver
he doing is maneuvering to e4
five f3
d7
trade ponds
wants to build a crusher
I was weird
you
I'm gonna win 85 is gonna win b6s I play
Bishop c7
might be an option Bishop c7
X on each six
could play f4
now I want to get my Knight to d6 with
me
bughouse
so in one a night place
you
oh my gosh
doesn't work it almost works
Eureka's
as a sneaky move I want to play
you
debating whether to play it
yes if I play it it's extreme hope
chests
you
I'm not going to play it
that's also not a great move
on the tact
you
okay I'm gonna play Bishop f4 retreat
hink
like away the rook ooh okay now I see
the line in the line that I want
to walk into it
a moment
there's all these mating ideas on the
queenside
people in the chat knows they know
what's up
you
I'm not I'm trying to avoid looking at
the chats
but I see the moves being mentioned that
I'm doing
I'm not going to look at the chat for
the rest of the game because
I want to see something that I haven't
considered it turn out to be a strong
idea
yeah that's a move
play this I was really hoping for Rookie
7 if I remember I'll show it after the
game what would happen after Rookie 7
this is still a nice position he file is
going to be wrong hopefully
you
but windy for
you
but I'm gonna have like all my minor
pieces and my rook trying to organize
some meeting and aiding attack mating
net
him like he has no immediate attack
against my king
is probably debating which pawn to take
I win material
though
yes this is okay
it might be three as well
I could take and then so many decisions
to make and it take it looks most fun
and rooks you
they keep the potential for mating
attack
this is a tag this is attacked this is
the ultimate target
you
the B force made somehow
you
ah that's so nice maiden to queen H a
queen
okay one line I want to show there like
there are all these ideas of meeting
with the bishops like sack in the nine
and see six
like this is a moment I wanted to play
96
it's such a beautiful idea if my Kings
on see 296 probably works
as if take meats
if he takes here then I meet like this
the problem is he could take on d3
that's why I would need my king uncie to
Lama Lord how's it going good to see you
oh yeah I was trying to like I've spent
a lot of time I was calculating this
this and see if it was worth taking the
risk but I mean black is probably just
surviving here and Rakim b7
and the other thing I wanted are is
hoping for is yeah rookie 7 verse rookie
6 is more logical but rookie 7 here then
96 I think is very strong
because I'm threatening mate in two with
97 Bishop c7 and if he takes and I have
made into with Bishop a6 Bishop c7 the
beautiful way to finish thing
okay back to tournaments to join the
tournament again 30th place keep moving
up
I take b6 in that knight c6 line
um
I'll take a look real quick
8b 6
in the 96 line
after rook c7
waiting for again
wait what happened brookey 796 yes when
I take p6 I would just take the rook
probably in material
um I was just fantasizing about all the
possible checkmates
now I'm playing a good player I'll
berserk and I'll play the London I'm
gonna have I ever slightly better score
against
now we just have a foots game
London Bishop b5
you
so I just made a course on the London
and this is literally the first game I
show in the course is uh
is a Carlson game and e4 is just so
strong here this is just a bad line for
a black
you
I play this guy in the same line before
yeah I did this is a position yeah okay
yeah this is a same position we've
reached and this was almost identical to
the Carlson game this finish with b4
well the goal in this game is to get
that position
okay so he realizes what's up
I guess I can't get too excited but I'm
just winning material here I think
wait a minute 96 I can take with the
bishop now
and a-five I haven't seen before
you
I'm you're here
you
and my gut tells me to take on d6
go for the sign if I take on seat I'll
be not good
you
each gift idea
you
hmm
you
tantrum
using way too much time because I'm
trying to refute this line which
probably not refuting and it's going to
be a fight
it'd still be better there's all these
issues for black II 6 was probably
necessary
until a 95
we just chief
ultimate goal is together Queen to h6 or
anywhere on the H file
another goal is to infiltrate with my
Knights
ah
and before check
been annoying but gopher this line
you
if I'm sagging upon
you
you
click on each seven doesn't work though
you
sometimes what happens when an opponent
walks into your opening crap and then
you do something weird on the right
mental state
the right moves
this is gonna be a very double-edged
I
9h six four nine five six
you
you
playing too low
this
wait a minute
again going for 9h six
I really don't want to Queen trade
probably have to though
mmm so painful
you started out so good too
you
now he's considering keeping the attack
not trading Queens maybe taking
he can't take on be to his night would
be him
I'm not paying attention to the chat so
but I will afterwards the scheme
[Music]
beyond winning upon
got counterplay
I have to develop my rook or potentially
that move
and before Zod
I see
you
just gotta play quick
q I can't take there
it was frightening to take on d3 in
Bishop c4
you
that's a very strong move develop
another pond
you
arek f1 is coming
feel sort of alive
he's playing too strong
you
Oh
going for hope
where is my last chance
smooth
oh that was so unfortunate opening
preparation on wrong that's my first
loss of the day too
to see some new people in the chats
manas good to see you the ice
that game
eleven true Vlad 11 the follow
I don't want stockfish no turnoff
stockfish disabled okay going back
I mean white is better after 905 it's
just uh not enough time to think about
scheme
d6
I did take 96 but maybe I should take
I just went upon thanks for the 10 bits
nice maybe this is simple big take take
if he thinks with Queen I take take take
but
one something more
I thought this offered me great
attacking chances
there's enough time to defend
okay now I'll turn on sock first I just
want to see what it says after net f5
for whites 96
be let me take off seven easy tactic
intermediate move why did I consider
that such a classic move to consider too
fortunate
it's still better for whites
for
95 bad move yeah cuz I probably just IV
I've just forgot about Quinn before a
check
if I take here
we know for is a nice move
okay lesson learned
dr. tournaments
thank you for that follow who is ass
miss to that follow is from but thank
you ever you are
awesome 2005 thank you well player
Budapest
is woop ng still here and he is still
here we have another Budapest
I can go up and read the comments
hacks villager explaining notation and
is for nights the Edna's for night
because K is for king
oh I forgot to Berzerk this game
I'll be ok get some cooldown
from the 850
nice
yeah I am curious like what the level
of the audience is
I think I've I did some survey of the
people who watch my stream I think it
like ratings are usually in the range
between like a thousand to 1,800 but I'm
sure there's people
outside both ends of that range
have you ever tried 94 trap no I have
not experiment with 94 I have seen the
the max boogie viral video though
against Ricky mates
I'll eat one of the most viral chess
videos of all time on the front page of
Reddit with that trap
but I've just gotten comfortable playing
normal Budapest
I like these lines with rook Asics
lifting the rook over
probably us rating would be best us or a
few day we chess is too confusing
sometimes
but yeah if everyone wants to say like
their their us or feed a rating I would
be interesting just for me to get a
sense of what level I should be
explaining things at
Brooke a6 is a bit coffeehouse move I
did have coffee this morning though
coffee's done non-caffeinated
or before it's a good move
a bishop on the same diagonal is a king
he's probably gonna play c5 blocking my
bishop and hitting my rook
but then rock g6
all I want to do is checkmate him
others to do
you
some people sharing their readings
1,700 feed a hundred USCF I forgot that
was hanging I don't really care
OSE sevens hanging
I don't know if I care about that either
all I care about is meeting
I mean almost all of the back pieces had
some potential to play a role in the
attack
this is now interesting and Bishop
some power
you
time to think
we need three is a forcing move
what else my chief forest option 96 is
an option
trying to calculate queen h3
work f2
or Bishop f3
a bishop a three blenders
now he has to play with
or g3
they rigged up to
you
I don't see anything immediate
you
only thing I see is Queen h3 rogue up to
96
and
I threatened the experi I would have 94
if he plays Bishop c3
and it's okay okay
sometimes you have to play a move and
accept uncertainty there I just wanted
to calculate everything
I have initiative for a few more moves
ideally I would like to keep the
initiative
I'm realizing there's some potential
meets imagine rook f2 knight c6 Bishop
c3 g6 he can't take obviously he can't
take on e6 cuz this pin if he takes on
g6 there's Queen g2 means
so
I think that the plan is to play d6 at
some point Bishop f3 is plunders
um he's probably not watching this
or maybe he just missed that I started
some plunder is now I just take on f3
that's nice
um
yeah it would have been interesting if
you played better after we got to this
would expect Bishop c3 and then d6 aims
to make this bishop happier and this
Bishop happier
it would be a fight from here like king
h1 Queen h4
of what happen okay back to tournaments
get my streak back I get some
watermelon juice
I'm gonna start a game dress
actually now I'm gonna start again play
the opening and then get some eats
that's the most efficient option it may
have been ignoring the chat for a while
difference between USCF and feed a
UFC offers USCF ratings are given by the
US Chess Federation bday ratings are
given by the my feet aiso
most people who aren't from the US will
not have the u.s. rating
malkin berserk this game
by my main preparation
playing really quickly
or some movin in d5
if he takes I probably play Nancy
an e5 leads to standard structure
who calculates your ratings after you
play so if you play in like a u.s.
tournament then after the tournament
finishes all the results get sent to the
US best ratings office and usually they
post ratings by the next like few days
and they have some algorithm you rating
can go up and down based on who you beat
and who you lose to
the lower rated you are the more
fluctuation and occur so if you're like
a 1000 rated player you can very easily
in 100 points or lose 100 points of
wonderment
if your my rating and your like
you're only 400 those tournaments I play
I won't gain or lose more than 15 points
okay what to do here
I can take with night but
while higher rated you go the harder it
is to actually gain rating
a lot of people a sometimes flat toe
like me I've been plateaued for a while
now
I actually plateaued for four years at
2,400
within two tournaments I gained 100
points I got to $24.99 I guess 99 points
and then I proceeded to lose all of the
points over the next light year but I'm
still around like 2400
but actually that was my us rating my
feet a rating during that spike
I broke 2400 feet and I'm 23 50 feet eh
at least I got the IM title
really been paying attention to what I'm
doing here
I had this plan to get juice but I found
the right time to take a break maybe
here
to bishops I didn't get juice I'm gonna
be right back
no I'm not so annoying
we do too
I would love to trade and go into some
endgame with the bishop parrot but if I
trade and he takes I can't preserve my
bishop
I could still play on
a kanji to a queen a seven
I think I'll still go for that line we
trade trade in 96 I have a past a pawn
supported by my rook
and these open files will be used to
bacchus plants
time to get juice
letting me get you I've made
you
you
you
okay
96
that's what helped me LC wants to
LifeLock aid the pawn
I beat Fabiano Caruana in chess actually
I did
um
a bunch of bullet games like a year ago
he wants to draw on draw
you
i'm throwin ian cheddar is following is
a surreal Fiona
long time this is like one of my
I was about to say fans but I'm a fan of
Fiona thank you for the follow Fiona
okay I have to actually focus on this
position as it is imbalanced
as pawns are in dark squares which
actually play well in restricting my
bishop
move like g5b pass for open the position
to do
each six-five
this Amin question here is what does
white want to do
because if one has no plan then I'm fine
playing h6
Thanks Iren 137 for the father
I don't see a clear plan for whites he
never wants to play c4 it's not now
let's play h6
and be patience
ah
in sequence with the raid thank you main
sequence
to keep up with all these notifications
and the comments in the chat the other
pics thanks for the follow ok so now
he's revealing his plan actually 93 or
night
entered to play this
like this first
you
um someone asked a question that I was
trying to answer
oh yeah the Fabiano BV chest thanks for
the follow
let me try and tell this story while
figuring out what to play here
boom-shaka-laka thanks for the follow I
want to play this looks risky
not necessary
this looks exciting
we'll be just bad
oh the smooth
should be for can be interesting
probably just bad
I don't know it's a weird position but
again I don't see what he wants to do I
probably have time
what do I want to do
what can the position be improved my
night would be happy on c4 it's hard to
get there
the play Bishop t6
Bishop d6 and gypsy seven
you
I see
you
I'm just gonna play King g7 it's just a
slightly improving move because I don't
know what he's going to do here
I have time to read the chat
elastic old asking about emotes
still need to tell the story how I beat
Fabiano but that will have to hold off
so he really wants to see five square
so once rugby seven
and also wants to flag me
to do
my pieces are just misplaced
have to rearrange let's start with this
it looks pointless you're gonna see
spawns but I want to do this in this
and I see five will be met with Roque
seven
and it'll be a fight
but I give a lecture for a signal
distress Club I think a lot of people
have seen this video on the London and
the first game I show in that lecture is
my supposed victory over Aviano and I
got confirmation that like 99% it was
him um oh no tie plunder
um but anyway it was like a bullet match
he was playing anonymously he played
like 20 games ish
and he want almost all of them but I did
beat him in like 12 or 13 moves in the
London that was nice
I'm scared here White has tactics I was
not paying attention to
as scared of this move maybe I wasn't
too harmful though
I have this
to attack
find offensive
I like to see
Aoife
or
does anything
it's um that Foursquare
do this
yes I've made some small improvements
now I see some plan on playing like rook
see 696 a for our tonight see for even
these types of positions plans are very
important
okay okay three I have to move quickly
though
is that really threatening to an upon
because III is always attacked
I'll play Bishop t8
strange position I really want to play
96 to play this move
but an IP six allows him to take on a
five
play f5
you
things I want to do
six
there should be six
there's a chance he'll play 97 but then
there's a funny line let's imagine 97 I
take take take that doesn't work because
he takes takes and wins a bishop
I've made in that night of rs.5
if I fly right away to
this is so confusing I can also just
take by the way
wait wait wait I can take and then play
No
I'm gonna take and play rook aids I have
some sneaky threats
yeah sorry to the chat it's hard to read
all your comments but thanks for
interacting with each other Ian Shadow
has to run um good to see you if you
don't know though at least not here
anymore
old comment
he defends against the threats
a black could very well be worse here
but I have this move rook h8 to go for
counter play
and the spawn is a weakness backward
pawn
rook
pay for
quicker
you
as I say that I'm moving much slower I
have six check
away
in g6 is another waiting move I don't
know what to do
I want to play g4 at some points
probably
now G for the structure will trade
nights
going to be a positional wrecking game
you
you
evergage five
for
now he has a choice rook a3 I can play
this
so much tension
five is coming
you
this is gonna be an interesting finish
not sure what's going on
want to play f4
if he takes the pollen probably also
happy
rooks are stuck for the time being
time
you
probably not the best move
you
bill offering the draw
I probably wouldn't have taken it even
though I'm slightly worse here
bad move
I am playing for a win
despite having low time
they repeat be perky one
you
or rookie for
you
or her key 3a
q3 is the threats he's go under
you
you
mine's here
you
was unexpected
you
now my crooks are getting active
that's a good move
I was a very good
do this
- trade
like fizzle out to a draw
you
is fizzling out
I still have to watch my time though and
be too fancy here
fragment
to win that was unfortunate and always
get what you want
around here I just didn't play quick
enough
I was getting complex this
sometimes you need to play very
accurately
around here I thought maybe there is
some chances maybe chances for both of
us
probably good I didn't play rook c2 that
walks into rook c3 and white is probably
winning
anything here
I played rook c8 convert da is a threat
oh maybe I could have played g3 though
again with starfish
um g3 is interesting
as if Brooke t8
I can play G - threatening d1 queen with
check
very interesting take here here it might
be a draw
actually maybe it's not a draw because I
work is hanging in many lines and just
start checking
you
this is actually a really interesting
position
like here
and this king should run out of square
is like king Nia seven walks into this
anyway
so I've had a couple draws today hey I'm
playing Sultan again he just beat me all
the zerk again I played London on him
I'm gonna play London again he played
the same lion at least twice already
I want my revenge I'm gonna play quicker
this game
he knows what's up now at least I'm
armed with the preparation that I did
earlier
gonna play b6 now he's gonna play 905
yeah high five I play this with and
routing many times
the line but the games against Andrew
tang we're in bullets
this is let's lightly difference
we need to typical move
maybe I just played Bishop f4
he can't ever bail out with his Knights
and I have threats of g4
so he wants to play 96 this is very
common
over g4 and f3
Oh
it's fun
I'm opponent after eeeh actually helps
restrict and your box play just like
this whole set up as a tempting could to
go for this e4 square hey it's a bit
Thank You vinyl chessboard
you appreciate that
um but he goes for this he wants to play
f6 for some trade
maybe bishop or is the threats
I'll just castle
I want to playroom make everything happy
do you make hot chocolate
it's not the season for hot chocolate so
I don't know why you're asking that
unless you live in Mike
even Iceland is it's warmer summer
um berserk too if someone asks a
question and I don't see it or I don't
answer people should I answer it for
other people
buzzer King cuts your time in half but
if you win if you win the game then you
get more points for the tournament
if I win this game I'll get three points
of two points if I didn't is Erick
all southern hemisphere swing I forgot
about the southern hemisphere
is that where who died really is
um and hot chocolate
after take me six a week yes the play
king of Saturn
then Bishop b5
what is going on
this is my problem sometimes I'm
perplexed with a position then I take
too long and I get on time but I have to
keep my time advantage
think our Bishop be 500 Bishop e5 the
knight can take it
about
let's just gain space thanks for the
follow alpha blow man blah man
you're 1,100 and you want to improve so
this is this is a comment or question
that people in the chat should try and
help out with I know many people
watching used to be 1,100
I want to give their tips for
improvements that would be nice just so
I can think
it's gained more space
the goal is to maybe do this
now it's harder for him to play g6 he
really wants to play e5 but he forgot
about this should be 5
and I play this first
papi
you
the plan is to maneuver my knight to
degree for its best place and then maybe
someday night or
you
he wants to play Bishop fix
allowance
maybe it's a bit uncomfortable
you
but there's a six-year I think I can
take on East
everything should work out
build up more pressure this is exactly
what I wanted
so now he has Bishop a six and then take
that's a good price
I might go back the exchange to in a few
ponds
attack the spawn
weren't on each five he could play g6
now life is good
you
up on a play rookie seven
maybe h6
trade
do this
you
and 11 on your donut hanging pieces yeah
usually a the love like any level below
1500 it's all about minimizing blunders
if you can play a game and not make any
like serious mistakes not give your
opponent gifts one of the best ways roof
a lot of that has to do with like
constantly asking yourself that your
opponent wants to a player with what the
threat isn't
and then of course taking advantage of
your own opportunities
but easier said than done
by a mouse this a long time ago
now I wasn't using the mouse like this
is my mouse like $50 as all these
functions which I don't use the zerk
another in London
I wasn't using the mouse because my
computer only has two USB ports and one
was for my microphone and other was for
my webcam though I had to make some
sacrifice but then I bought a USB hub
and then all all the things I need can
be plugged in actually really nice
my only mistake was I didn't order it
online I went to Best Buy and it was
just severely overpriced I paid $30 for
like a this is a piece of plastic with
like four USB ports
but it came with like this wall charger
unnecessary cable
that's what I get for going to Best Buy
I'm sure twitch won't mind you saying
that given that Amazon owns twitch I
should have Amazon
if he wants to cause problems like we
need 323 is a typical move these
positions
discouraging any e5 because now the rook
is
hang on the D file 9h five I will admit
that I'm out of any preparation as a
position I should probably be prepared
for I think I can play Bishop E
taking on d4 doesn't work for
I won't promote 84 because I could
actually take on
as far as I'm sure
does walmart own Best Buy is that true
I should take
so be an interesting position
which would be better I wants to attack
oh I can take care
vile to realize it okay he can't take
back with a pawn and if he takes with 9n
or move
this is what I want I want to play
Bishop you do and pick him around
and it's all about seizing the
initiative
here I still keep
you
[Music]
you can
initiative
to the fans
it's a bit crowded on the kingside
things should be under control you can
take on h2
Brook to you one looks attractive
95 looks attractive
you
each 39.6 attacking
you
Oh
to think
maybe Bishop d3
all in move
make sure this is defended so then in
the future
my night will have more mobility
and I might want to play out five very
soon a five runs in 95 I don't know what
I wanted to do but seems like he also
doesn't know what he wants to do
though on level terms I was about equal
no time to look at the chat fix
boom
by h3
a night of 692
continue to be solid
maybe soon I'll play rook g1
expand somehow
ooh he's expanding
or both expanding the e5 looks very nice
g1 and then night at five
- Queen
first guess I'll take up on who he takes
on f2
okay I'll play Queen III
because efore is uh is going to be
an eventual snack
time I want to keep things defended
were cure
it takes my rook least then I can
improve my Knights
and then I'm once
sir - my goal lover of g1 Knight f5
pawns hanging forgot about that part
that's embarrassing
it's a sign that I'm sleepy I probably
need to stop playing chess
but I'm going to fight here be6
like a fighting move
you
it's for Twitter a popular
ice worked at Best Buy for 10 years
when the circuit when
Oh
[Music]
fortunate
I've complicates things
seven
obvious candidate move will be necessary
myyy conscious of weakness
I'm gonna have to work to win this game
down like two pawns
for some reason he's thinking
I could piss
I'm allergic to bad position
at least I'm up on time
in the s7 pond
Oh yesa four-on-two majority on the
kingside I have a three-on-two majority
on the inside
back
slow down this plan
majority is my time majority
you
am I to see war
I'm here
you
I'm for Kim
if he doesn't get worked in the next 30
seconds that'll be very impressive
my night is going to turn into a monster
urge him even more
yes
you
we'll take that
to be careful also not to get forked
but truth
upon
ah he can fork me on d3 good thing he
didn't see that
this it's time to Fagin
very
you
well he didn't get forked I guess I'm
impressed
he is flagging
okay I'm sorry for that
sometimes you gotta resort to time
I'm in 21st place three hours left when
he points to I have 43 Zuber is leading
the pack
hello I am
bad positions or bad players I don't
know
probably just allergic to like dust all
in and springtime
you
okay I don't know how many more games
I'm going to play but you want to run
next it's my running partner
well it's weird but I texted a friend to
run and they didn't respond
and those other day I text them again
I don't run too far I usually just run
and listen like an audiobook
or sometimes even walk and listen to an
audiobook but today's good weather to
run
let's play e6 we have a Smith Mora a fun
opening
you
okay let me send a text
I can be too focused on the position but
I'm still in opening preparation
you
you
rookie one on other prep
one
like 94 is a move
5's idea
and what to do here
we need to is the main line also e5 is a
line
rookie one
ninety-five probably isn't too scary
because I can take with pawn and play
like 97
well that's the case let's just play
Bishop I
you
the one drawback but I know in these
lines when they play this early rookie
one f2 is sometimes early targets
Wow so he's going all out I just
discarded this move is after taketake 97
what is he doing
well if I lose at least I'll learn so I
don't see what his point is
it was just to try and keep the king in
the center
I want a castle next move
lady six next move
you will get some pressure
I think he just played 95 knowing that
it's a typical idea not realizing it
doesn't work in this position but we'll
see
the best is not to accept this myth
Maura I I enjoyed accepting this myth
more if black is well-prepared then
accepting is uh is very playable you
just have to be prepared for these sharp
lines
of g5
we just castle
I'm allowing him to take and give me
double pawns and I mean if I could get
my g6 and be very safe
yeah I don't listen to a whole audiobook
line
but I run but I listen to portions of it
I got the subscription to audible cuz I
realize like the last
six to seven years
this is embarrassing but I probably
haven't read more than like two books
um I listen to like a ton of like
podcasts bigger than
um all your books would be a good good
way to stay smart
he's six maybe then before ideas
you
do
as before isn't that harmful
which it has no discoveries
I'm sure twitches is thrilled that I'm
mentioning all the bulb because it's
another another thing that's owned by
Amazon
I got
really have like a chroma link
on sir ship or something ex villager
sharing audible yeah you can get you can
usually get a free audiobook or you can
get two for your audio books if you have
Amazon Prime
but I own about that site if that was a
temporary promotion but I got two free
audiobooks and then it's like $15 a
month for one book a month
for people who don't have the patience
to read or like me I'm just slow at
reading it's a slow reader
you
oh yeah
I should have liked these promo links
anytime I promote a product people can
buy the product also if you have Amazon
Prime you can subscribe for free and
support the channel another thing
East six no he's running before
hey Paragon
subscribe using twitch crime there we go
Thank You Paragon
Queen b6 since backing two pawns
I want to play d6 next
developments
my king is pretty safe
you
maybe I can even use the G file for some
attack
Mutato cheats
you don't accept this that's more trying
to refute it
yeah I mean if you play night at 6:00 on
move Paragon Paragon just followed to
not too many people subscribe and then
follow thanks for the follow yeah if you
wanted to like if you're a Sicilian
player and you're scared of Smith Morra
you can very easily play Knight of 6 in
this position exposes into c3 Sicilian
lines or d5
Oh playable but
I like this line
you
fight over pushes
or speaking of over pushing let me just
take that
very tempted to take on anyone well a
good move I'm just tempted
but queen c5 looks like a good
as now he's forced to either trade
Queens or allow me to take on me one
the arrow there
oh I'll be better with my targets
hello always beast 11 always beast 1
also people and their names with one
only a couple of people
okay I like my position I probably show
the desserts but it is nice to have some
slower pace games only problem is it's
hard to catch up in the tournament
well three hours left
you
July 905
other names I don't recognize like a lot
of new viewers today thanks everyone
who's sticking around
has been a longer stream than usual
a MOT juice one two three thanks for the
follow
I'm just yeah my and bishops are
sometimes why they hated the nature of
bishops
you can see they're playing a match
against non without me I would okay this
guy just resigns thanks for the game I
played John
like in his early days of YouTube I
think if you'd like type into YouTube
Eric Rosen John Bartholomew and fine are
a one-match that we did play
unhook gee thanks very sudden
I will try and stream more regularly at
least the next week or two
astonishing leaving the parade in
Laughlin show
it's a Braden laughlin show
laughs in another regular viewer who I
haven't seen today fire hunt 3 but
thanks for the follow
you
yeah I would play John
I played John we would probably play on
chess calm okay with me
um
[Music]
not sure what would take to set that up
I got a message the other day from
elitist mod asking if I wanted to like
do some match or some promotional match
with another leech a streamer
so I haven't done like an organized
match yet
pretty cool I'm gonna play where they
normally play Queens pawn means grab it
declines
I was teaching a student earlier today
I'm gonna play what I taught him
I usually don't play this myself I
wanted to play Cambridge Springs Bishop
f4 is a move
if it's a great move though because
that's all I can take
it's usually better on
should before
this is already very good free back
attacking this in this preparing b5
played that really quickly like it was
opening preparation
and now I'm happy okay
you
pants reading your comment
um yeah I'll take that into account I
think a lot of people have preferred
slow games today is definitely a slower
day terms of mind control though yeah
hopefully it's more enjoyable I realize
it does give me more time to interact
with the chats as well
thanks for the follow a one something
something something
okay queen h5x pleasant
if I looks very strong
I supposed to take money for it but
that's not hanging
we take on f4
and then play b5 happy
they'd be five immediately
you
don't play b5 immediately
it does give them the opportunity to say
this bishop
let him make that decision and then in
the meantime I just want to improve
complete development hassle this should
be sudden bad with drawing arrows today
really I just want to improve the visit
ouka 25
after watching the video
I wanted to explore more can you
recommend something
oh wait I recommend something what would
you want me to recommend something in
the London or some other opening or be
more specific
recommend this watermelon juice vicious
from Trader Joe's as cucumber in it
that's the recommendation you wanted
a castle here
the great thing about the phone and see
for as it takes away the d3 square
[Music]
weights are to keep up
I'm just waiting for poker to specify
a vinyl chess board shared the study
link that's great
yeah the study link has like a nice game
collection of there's a lot of studies
on the London on me chess if you just
type in like go to Lee chess org slash
study and then type in London a lot of
people have made like good public
studies collections of games and line
recommendations
and you can do that with any opening so
if you're interested in like learning
like the French just type in French and
I would expect like the the higher
quality studies to be the first ones
that show up
given their the rating system how many
people have like ah vada have lights the
studies
anyway what to do I can take on a for
now
you
once the castle
upon
that much
you
I have an interesting idea
probably not good I'm thinking about
taking this pawn and then Bishop a6
just gonna play 97 no reason to take too
much time
axe village you're asking if I've played
chess hustlers on the streets yes I have
I started like when I was
a second when I was eight years old but
like I played always when I was pretty
young
I'm probably when I was eight or nine
there's a place in Chicago wants to meet
me let's play nine of six
in Chicago they play on the beach like
this chess pavilion that's probably
right my first variance against hustlers
it would usually play for money
and win money is like a young kid $2
I played in New York a few times
Washington Square Park
what's other one like Central Park or
Bryant Park I think they play too
to attack me
usually the main goal is to play c5 at
some points
you
I don't know I'm just gonna play h6
in f1 such a asks seemingly confident
move I can't take on g5 I don't think
unless I can
take on c3 and take on a4
that looks fun actually and do this
because I'm winning more material
and the point is that now I can win his
Knights which I think he forgot about
moving a bit too quickly this game
I'm threatening this and this and this
or bits
always be one thank you for the bits
maybe referring to the London video
I'm trying to keep up with the questions
cheery Cara's I have zero grandmaster
norms richen I've been closed a couple
times hard together diem ORN them I'm
very far away from it I don't I have no
norms my feet a rating was like 23
a cent at a
slightly depressing
okay take and then I
wait a minute they come I don't know let
me play f5
structures so aesthetic everyone
but be files only open file on the board
I want to play rugby too
okay he resigns a game
yeah I think that game was a nice
example of why you shouldn't play Bishop
f4 in that semi slob position
Bach just takes on c4 holds onto the
pawn
um what is your USCF rating and feed a
rating
if you go to I am Rosen calm I usually
don't don't promote my site liked
unprompted but if you go to iron Rosen
calm scroll down to the homepage you can
see uh you can see my readings hey I'm
playing a strong player via London
if you type in the about command moobot
should link to my websites would think
recommendation against the London weight
recommendation about London's
so you want the recommendation to learn
the London like what resource to use or
what to play well here I have a London
so maybe I can recommend how exactly to
play this line I usually like to start
with Bishop f4 and then Knight f3 the
more you play the more you realize that
move order can be important like here C
3s would be a mistake because between
musics I like to play Knight bTW to MF
Queen b6 Rose
although Rika thinks for the sub
um what was I saying if Queen b6 I would
have taken us
this is actually a cool line if he falls
into this trap
Queen 84 is tricky
sevens of us knows what he's doing
this is sort of like a reverse Cambridge
things
a I for one too
improve
it's China the best feelings booth
the view
or with your influence
a queen bee six
there's a few common ideas for whites
or is one idea
I see
you
I can also just castle
let's counsel
I'm not going to convince usually in
chess you don't want to play you want to
play the moves you know you're going to
play first I know I'm going to Castle
eventually
not sure if I want to play c4 eventually
or eventually 95
axe villager assuring my bio link but my
bio actually doesn't have my ratings
homepage my ratings
um I have not updated my stream schedule
while my streams have been kind of when
I feel like it
uhh
I apologize for that I know I should do
better
I keep saying to myself and to people
that I'll have a schedule soon
I'm gonna play c4
you
you make a living off chess if you
become an IM that's a good question you
can't make a living off playing chess
but you can certainly make a living off
- yes
or doing doing some sort of like
entrepreneurial ever involving chess a
lot of people are doing at least
Oishi with explosion of online chess
online coaching and streaming journalism
there's lots of opportunities not only
to make a living but just to have like a
a side job
okay let's think about this position I
can just take care
I can see six
you
you
I'm feeling the fatigue I've been
streaming for a while
realizing it's probably not worth my
time I am in 13th place I think it's
worth my time playing this whole
tournament only
yeah if your top 50 in the world then
you can probably make them
top 20 make a very good living playing
Jess
I love wrong Invitational events with
very good prize money
but everyone else
it's not the most glamorous lifestyle if
you're just playing Jess
you
I'll take
play some positional game
it's not the best option
you
asked to do
you
but the other thing I'll say like if
you're an I am usually it's I am and
above if you go to like international
events like for me I've been going to
Europe went to Australia about six
months ago I can find tournaments set
will provide me hotel and sometimes
appearance fees sometimes food and I
found it that it's a great way to travel
because it really reduces Austin
of travel in general
so
I've been basically spending the last
year traveling a lot to international
events and then
it's taking advantage of conditions that
I got free hotel reduced hotel and then
teaching online and in playing a good
amount to
while chessboard thanks for the hundred
bits
you know espalier asking about what I
think about Norway
I mean Norway is super strong events
I'll admit I haven't not been following
it too closely
I've been following like basic like
minds I know about ding
surgery or whatever
screenshot of the Caruana game versus
I'm rooting for Fabiano wasn't Nakamura
leading going into this round
like it's been a good tournament for
Americans
I probably have to take
you
you really calculate that I mean had to
do it
he's attacking v2
we know three could be a very facing
move
hitting the pawn
bubble a juicy lyric yet
it's awkward
the open beats be first
even rook c2 first
you
not sure
it's a root it's
Hey
oh yeah oh we don't want that
okay I'll play b3 one nice thing about
this position is my bishop controls this
BH square so you never really get it
ripped increase pressure along the file
now he does have the two bishops but
they're not so menacing
Queen b5 interesting I think I want to
take
probably have to play Queen a3
a play rook e8
well like we do
ah then he's going to play c4 that's
okay
be fine for me he plays c4 I think I
have this
the C file will open police open up for
me
we would win in chessboxing between me
and hammer being based on his name alone
last name is a lot more intimidating
also I don't box
don't really do contact sports
you
I like sports with Nets where you're
like away from your opponent like I'm in
sir
or volleyball
okay I'm in that when see - I guess it
out of the pin
I do like my position
there's so much pressure
just have to move quicker
a strategy for racing Kings I don't know
rata G would be too
look at the games of the top players on
the chest and copy them he wants to play
Bishop f5
I mean g4 looks ridiculous
take
if I've almost traps I play trip d1
Bishop f5 oh then I've queen bee
I have to move quicker
less talk and more moving
you
you
calculating weird lines here
probably not work efore into mind he for
take take
might be one
I'd be one I consider this move earlier
and I didn't like it
I guess it makes sense I want to play
Queen d2 and Knight e3 and maybe 94 I
would be the dream a neo espalier thanks
for watching
okay this might be my last game I'm
tired I finish off strong or chest I
play the more energy it takes out of me
you
I'm glad he's thinking here it's gonna
come down to some time scramble
um cherry cars thanks for watching
but it's not over yet watching
basketball I guess basketball does have
him that
the count that I didn't play basketball
on yours
the last time I played basketball was
with Carlson
probably the only reason we played
basketball
Karlsson is pretty good at basketball
doesn't have the forum but he has a
athleticism
World Championship
made me play this game first
you
I like my position I'm really happy with
my p1 in Queen d2
good rearrangement this is they're still
going to be pressure on the C file I
they for us coming
honest offended
a five I take on d5 as a tactic
this is a common tactical idea when the
queens are aligned
just winning upon now
the key is an intermediate move if he
takes I take the bishop back
now I'm happy up upon still down on time
it's not too bad
in see ponds are weak
and I'm assuming he's gonna trade then
his c6 phone will be weak
maybe he'll play Bishop d3
you
actually I still have to be careful
the bishop here
looks weird but I want my night to be
defended he plays rookie - then I could
play rookie one
you
also like to do stuff like this
upon okay this is looking nice
attack III
see six
one of this
tricky
G for Bishop d3
I'm Knight f3 first
things are getting weird which is
probably what he wants
it confuses me
we might thread it's to play 9h for
Bishop d3 rook FD one
my chief either simmer
you
all about removing this Bishop from
defending the Knights
uhh
oh he won this pawn back
i skewer him he has 92 coming
very well played
on time
you
unless they play 92
okay down the minutes it's not really
what I wanted
objectively whites should be fine my
bishop is happy
one point I'll come back to III
lay this first
you
letting upon
I have to play much much quicker
you
trying to make it uncomfortable for him
you
I'll slow him down
five
five
another five
I've somehow
much better here
Oh
you
20 seconds left
am i king
you
Oh what am i doing
you
I'm playing for some last stalemate Rick
I want to walk my king to h4
and then I have an alcohol doesn't even
work
the game well played
what do they do
now I want upon--and got too comfortable
you got counterplay is creative
I take to you for a good move
and I'm still probably just better here
just play like roof t1
excellent III
you
and his pieces were just more active
you
okay
and you kind of want to go over them
not for too long I just want to see
stock fish like whites white should have
the advantage but I don't know about how
much like let's point five maybe
you
or if I play accurately bh6
or
Brooksie for I didn't even consider
Brooksie for is a nice move though
let me ask when I
like currently this is a the video
synced with the audio
is right now it's like showing a lot of
lag and OBS I think it's because I
turned on stockfish it takes up a lot
more CPU power
um on the turn off suckish
oh it's not synched has it been synced
the whole time
or has it not been synced the whole time
just turned off stockfish let me know if
that helps
um
was okay for most of the stream
it seems when I turned off sausage okay
this is good to know I have no idea what
causes it probably just CPU
um oh I could turn off this or turn down
the seat
right oh it's cuz it's set to five I
want like one I just want like some
quick
right now
okay now it looks seems
yeah hopefully that helps I don't
realize it was set to five
great to know a tactical wizard when is
a classical shield arena
a way to figure that out I'm in the
closet tournament
um other fun tournaments I go back to it
I finished I almost brought broke top
ten
um I've yet to win a shield maybe
someday
go to like tournaments I see the
upcoming tournaments
they turn minutes
and then
be somewhere here
is there a way to see the list of the
shield arenas
the 2018 HS anniversary
that's cool
I'm at I don't know if I'll be around
for that
I'll join
12-hour turn in 12-hour router
tournament
ah going back
Oh classical shield is tomorrow
what's today Thursday I might play
tomorrow I'll see
along ten hours and hours
I can be productive today if I go for a
run today
at my work done
yeah I'll see maybe I'll stream part of
it probably the most likely scenario
anyway I'm gonna leave it there anyone
else streaming whoa people are streaming
entertain
and scene and ruin while or 100 viewers
crazy okay
to rate Andrew everyone who's watching
this please join the raid penguin em1
and I will see you guys in the future